Trascrizione: rosanna valente
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Vera Gheno:"Buonasera! Ciao!".
Matteo Maggiò: "Benvenuta, grazie!
Gomitino - anche se spero
sarai vaccinata ormai, no?".
VG:"Sì, sì - Veccia muchacha
immunizada" hai presente?".
MM: (Ride).
VG:"Ok, divento seria".
MM:"Come stai, tutto bene?".
VG:"Tutto bene, grazie".
MM:"È un piacere vederti qui a Mestre.
Grazie per essere venuta,
per il tuo bellissimo talk".
VG:"Felicissima".
MM:"Ci hai parlato di"schwa",
di differenze, di inclusività.
Sai che oggi abbiamo
questa grande staffetta
fra oltre 24 TEDx italiani
che parlano di democrazia digitale.
E ti chiedo subito,
ma secondo te
il digitale, ed il suo
linguaggio, è democratico?
VG:"Allora, dipende dai punti di vista,
nel senso - sicuramente,
come è già stato detto peraltro,
il digitale può aiutare
in molti casi, intanto,
a far sentire le voci di coloro
che prima non avevano una voce.
Ancora fino a, direi,
fino a 15/20 anni fa,
chi è che aveva una voce pubblica?
Qualcuno che aveva un motivo
per essere già un personaggio pubblico:
quindi un politico, non so,
un intellettuale, un VIP in generale.
E, se ci pensate,
loro detenevano, in assoluto,
il dominio della parola pubblica.
Quand'è che spuntava una voce,
diciamo, non conosciuta?
Ma ci sono stati
degli esperimenti interessanti,
che hanno fatto storia,
per esempio quando Radio Radicale,
a un certo punto, apre i microfoni
e scopre un "Lato B", quasi,
dell'Italia, degli italiani
e dell'italiano,
che prima non era così noto.
"Oh mio Dio! Le persone
parlano davvero così?".
Oppure quando, non lo so,
in qualche telegiornale
si dà il microfono
alle persone per strada.
Però, di norma,
la voce pubblica era di pochi.
Era un'aristocrazia, diciamo così.
Cosa ha fatto la rete,
e soprattutto i social?
Effettivamente, ha dato voce
a chi prima una voce non ce l'aveva.
Poi, ovvio, sui grandi numeri, ci sono:
molti che la usano così così;
alcuni che la usano
davvero male, per fare il male;
e alcuni che invece ci fanno delle cose
francamente molto interessanti.
Per esempio, vediamo
le giovani generazioni
che fanno delle cose che già io,
alla loro età, non avrei potuto fare.
Quindi, da questo punto di vista,
la rete e i social soprattutto,
sicuramente hanno
un effetto democratizzante.
Però è vero che poi
c'è un altro tipo di divario,
che è quello digitale in senso stretto:
cioè noi parliamo da un punto
di vista euro-centrico,
ma non tutto il mondo ha le stesse
possibilità di accedere, no?
alle possibilità digitali,
ai mezzi digitali.
Quindi bisognerebbe, anche,
lavorare in quel senso lì,
cioè rendere la voce pubblica
davvero pubblica.
Lo sta diventando piano piano.
Poi si pone un secondo problema
che è come usare questo potere".
MM:"Ci lavoreremo" - VG:"Certo!".
MM:"Pian pianino.
Senti, tu sei -
come sociolinguista, diciamo,
sei stata una cronista
di queste trasformazioni
che sta subendo la nostra lingua.
In particolare,
da sempre sei attenta e sensibile
alla comunicazione digitale.
Quanto, secondo te, è oggi
influenzata la nostra società
da questa evoluzione del nostro
nuovo modo di comunicare?".
VG:"Ma allora, intanto, secondo me,
occorre conoscere una cosa,
considerare un aspetto;
e l'aspetto è che la società,
la realtà che viviamo
e di conseguenza, la lingua che parliamo
cambiano di continuo.
Benjamin Whorf, che è il padre
della teoria della relatività linguistica,
a un certo punto fa ricorso
a un, come si può dire?
un concetto della fisica quantistica,
per spiegare la relazione
fra lingua e realtà,
e dice che le due stanno in una sorta
di "entanglement quantistico",
il che vuol dire che,
nel momento in cui noi cerchiamo
di separare la realtà dalla lingua,
facendoci delle domande tipo:
"Ma viene prima la lingua
o viene prima la realtà?",
è un po' come la questione
dell'uovo della gallina,
cioè è una cosa, lui diceva,
che occorre considerare nel suo intreccio.
E quindi, in realtà,
la lingua è cambiata di continuo.
Il motivo per cui oggi lo vediamo di più
è perché questo cambiamento
ha subito un'accelerazione notevole,
negli ultimi 60 anni.
E come mai?
Perché prima, semplicemente,
gli italiani non parlavano italiano.
Perfino Manzoni, che ha scritto
"I promessi sposi", si sa, in italiano
è venuto a sciacquare
i panni in Arno, eccetera eccetera -
con gli amichetti parlava francese,
cioè la lingua della cultura
del momento era francese.
L'italiano era ancora
molto sperimentale, mettiamola così,
ma soprattutto molto in vitro,
cioè non era la lingua
davvero usata dalle persone.
Ci sono voluti cent'anni
dall'Unità d'Italia -
quindi dal 1861, più o meno cent'anni -
ci sono voluti 100 anni di scuola
e 100 anni di leva obbligatoria,
che costringeva i ragazzi a mischiarsi,
quindi il friulano che
si ritrovava con il siciliano,
naturalmente tendevano
verso una koinè, una lingua comune
e quindi diciamo
che anche questa lingua comune
era l'italiano, o almeno
un tentativo di italiano.
Ma questi non sono bastati:
c'è voluta un'altra cosa.
Cos'è che ha insegnato
l'italiano agli italiani?
La televisione.
In particolare, probabilmente,
molte persone conoscono
il mitico maestro Manzi
che si occupava, col suo programma
"Non è mai troppo tardi"
delle persone rimaste fuori
da tutte queste innovazioni,
cioè gli anziani.
E consiglio sempre a tutti
di andare online
e cercare i video del maestro Manzi,
perché io mi commuovo tutte le volte
quando c'è la vecchietta che riesce,
finalmente, a scrivere il suo nome,
dopo una vita da analfabeta.
Rende anche l'idea, il maestro Manzi,
di cosa voglia dire
avere la parola scritta,
ti dà tutta un'altra
consistenza nella società.
Finché firmi con la X,
diciamo che non puoi pienamente
partecipare alla vita della polis,
cioè della città in senso lato.
Non puoi fare a pieno titolo
parte della società.
Questa è anche l'importanza della parola,
parlata senz'altro, ma anche scritta".
MM: "Senti, parli, hai parlato
di società, di città
nel tuo ultimo talk
per gli amici di TEDx Firenze,
hai parlato di
'abitare la propria lingua'.
È un termine che a me, come architetto,
insomma, è molto caro:
cioè abitare un luogo, uno spazio,
vuol dire condividerne,
plasmarne in qualche modo l'identità.
Pensi che il nostro linguaggio
oggi rifletta la nostra identità,
cioè lo abitiamo comodamente,
con con facilità, con agio?".
VG:"Dipende da come siamo fatti.
Se rientriamo in quella che è stata
per tantissimi anni la "normalità",
diciamo che la abitiamo più comodamente.
Ovviamente il concetto
di "abitare la lingua"
è di Cioran, l'ho preso
in prestito da lui.
Lui dice: "Non si abita un paese,
ma si abita una lingua",
perché in realtà la cosa
che ci rende tribù, davvero,
non è il fatto di abitare in un luogo,
è il fatto di parlare la stessa lingua.
E fra l'altro, specularmente,
l'aspetto di differenza, di alterità
che istintivamente, come animali,
ci dà più fastidio
è parlare una lingua diversa.
Cioè, purtroppo, istintivamente -
questo lo dice Telmo Pievani -
abbiamo una parte xenofoba
che reagisce davanti, soprattutto,
alla differenza linguistica,
con un momento di "questa persona
è una nemica, è un alieno!"
Comunque, tornando a noi,
prendiamo atto di una cosa.
Non c'è da vergognarsi,
però la società, fino a oggi,
è stata molto normocentrica,
è stata normalizzante.
Vi faccio notare che la lingua stessa,
nel 99% dei casi, credo, al mondo,
è costruita sul maschile, è androcentrica.
Perché? Perché siamo tutti maschilisti?
In realtà no, perché
la storia è andata così.
Cioè gli uomini hanno fatto la storia,
le donne sono state,
molto spesso, dietro le quinte.
E quindi, diciamo che chi abita
veramente bene la lingua,
per esempio la lingua italiana,
sono le persone di sesso maschile.
Prima cosa.
Poi ci sono tutta un'altra serie
di distinguo da fare,
però non li faccio, perché sono lunghi.
Ma il punto è che, ad esempio,
il femminile piano piano sta emergendo.
Cambia la società, cambia il ruolo
della donna nella società,
cambia la lingua.
Molti hanno da ridire su questo.
Perché?
Intanto perché credo
che ci siano molte persone
che non si rendono conto
di avere un privilegio,
per esempio quello di essere
pienamente rappresentate
a livello linguistico.
"Che fastidio dà il maschile sovraesteso?
Si è sempre fatto così".
Voi capite l'iniquità di una regola,
che è aleatoria, come tutte
le regole della lingua,
che se ci sono 30 donne e un uomo,
dice di dire:"Buonasera a tutti".
Questo è il senso.
E qui mi sono ancora mantenuta
sulla questione del binarismo di genere,
quindi maschile e femminile.
Si sa, io sono a favore
dell'uso dei femminili professionali
e tutto il resto,
compreso almeno il doppio saluto
"Buonasera a tutti e tutte".
Ma mentre studiavo questa questione,
una persona non binaria
è venuta da me, e mi ha detto:
"Tutto bello, ma io sono
una persona non binaria,
e l'italiano non lo abito comodamente
perché l'italiano è un maschile,
o un femminile. Che si fa?".
Come ho detto nel talk,
è chiaro che possiamo dire:
"E vabbe', è una minoranza",
però nel momento in cui una persona
si mette a ragionare sui diritti,
in una prospettiva democratica,
non ci sono persone di serie A
e persone di serie B;
ed è un po' da questo
che nasce tutta la riflessione
che credo nei prossimi anni
giungerà a maturazione".
MM:"Senti, facci un pronostico:
secondo te questo esperimento linguistico
funzionerà, andrà bene,
verrà accolto dalla società parlante?".
VG:"Allora, io credo di no.
Intanto perché non stiamo parlando
di un'innovazione lessicale,
cioè delle parole, che sono lo strato
più superficiale di una lingua
e quindi quello che può
cambiare più velocemente.
Qui stiamo parlando di morfologia,
cioè del modo in cui, appunto,
si declinano le parole;
e prima che si tocchi la morfologia
ci vuole veramente un cambiamento grosso,
cioè ci vuole
che la maggioranza di una società
senta l'esigenza di questo cambiamento;
e credo che al momento non ci siamo.
Però molti linguisti,
che in generale si dicono, anche,
contro tutte queste forme,
fra virgolette, "inclusive",
pronosticano che una forma come lo"schwa",
o qualcosa di simile,
chissà cosa spunterà prossimamente,
potrebbe diventare comune
nelle formule di saluto,
di apertura e di chiusura.
Quindi "Buonasera a tutte,
tutti e tuttə", una cosa del genere.
Perché quelle, diciamo, sono
delle parti formulaiche della lingua;
e magari una persona,
per dimostrarsi inclusiva
o accogliente con tutti/tuttə,
potrebbe pure adottare,
anche a livello più ampio,
questa soluzione.
Ma che entri nella grammatica,
la vedo dura.
La mia speranza, non tanto segreta,
è riposta nelle generazioni nuove.
Io, non so voi,
ma ho una figlia di 13 anni
e lei non passa giorno
[senza] che mi dica:
"No mamma ma noi siamo fluidi.
Cioè queste cose, maschile e femminile."
E io dico:"Bello tutto,
va benissimo", io sono contenta.
Però ricordatevi, voi ragazzi,
che questa fluidità non è gratis,
ve la dovete tenere stretta,
perché nel momento in cui voi
arriverete alla maggiore età
ci sarà una società
che tenderà a normalizzarvi.
Però, se loro portano avanti
questo progetto di fluidità
sono sicura che troveranno una soluzione,
i linguisti del futuro,
alla quale noi non abbiamo mai pensato".
MM:"Largo ai giovani allora!".
VG:"Certo che sì, sempre!".
MM:"Vera ti ringrazio
per questa chiacchierata.
È stato un piacere
e spero che tutti voi
abbiate potuto apprezzare
questa nostra bellissima sorpresa
che ci è stata fatta.
VG:"Grazie grazie!". MM:"Grazie!".
(Applausi)